Italy is the only country, alongside with
Greece, that is poorer now than before having
the EURO as their official currency.
The figures leave no space for doubt; Italians
now have less purchasing power than before,
making them one of the few countries that
became worse off after joining the European Union.
We are talking about the second biggest industrial
power in all of Europe, only surpassed by Germany.
In fact, during the 90s, Italians were wealthier
than the British and the French.
If you are my age or older, you might remember
EROS RAMAZZOTTI, LUCIANO PAVAROTTI or the
so-called SPAGHETTI WESTERNS.
Yes, my dear viewers…
Italy was one of the biggest powerhouses on the planet.
And all despite their Government and their
ruling class.
The political history of Italy is…
How should I say it?...
Next to it, Game of Thrones would look like
Gilmore Girls.
Just remember: Italians have the Sicilian
COSA NOSTRA, the Calabrese N’DRANGRETTA,
the Napolitan CAMORRA
and many other gangs.
And yes, all of them have important connections
with the highest level politicians.
But there is more than Mafia here!
During the Cold War, some government officials
helped extreme right wing terrorist groups
that organized the most violent attacks you
could imagine.
And what about the extreme left wing?
Well, they didn’t stay quiet either.
The Red Brigades kidnapped and murdered an Italian Prime Minister.
Look, if you’re into scary stories, you
should google something about Propaganda Due.
Or you can just watch the movie ‘Il Divo’
from Paolo Sorrentino.
You will discover a fascinating country where
politics are everything but boring.
And now you might wonder….
What’s going on in Italy now?
Do they have as much instability as they did
in the 70s and the 80s?
And the answer is, oh you bet they do!
IN just 10 years, Italy has had 6 different
prime ministers.
In just 10 years!
In other words, Keeping up with Italian politics
is an impossible mission.
And this is why, in this video, we will not
talk about the Italian elections that have
been celebrated recently… not even about
Berlusconi’s love life.
Because the real question here is…
How is it possible that such a chaotic country
could manage to become that wealthy?
And what is happening now, after two decades
of economic stagnation?
Today we are going to answer both of these
questions but before we do, let’s take a
look back at The Good, the Bad and The Ugly
of Italian history.
GIULIO ANDREOTTI IS…
“THE GOOD”
During the 40s, the Italian Communist party
was the biggest of its kind all across Western
Europe.
With more than 1,300,000 members, they could
win an election anytime.
As you can imagine, in the middle of the Cold
War, this was something America could not
let happen.
So…
do you remember the MARSHALL PLAN?
If you’ve been following VisualPolitik for
a long time, you already know that Uncle Sam
sent lots and lots of money to Europe so they
could rebuild their destroyed cities.
When it came to Italy, this money was not
only meant to help the country but also to
finance the only political party who could
face the communist threat.
This party was called the CHRISTIAN DEMOCRACY.
“Mother, save your children bolchevism!
Vote Christian Democracy!”
During the following 50 years, Italy had 30
different prime ministers.
Yep, you heard that right.
This means the average age for an Italian
government was little more than a year and
half.
But they all had something in common: most
of them were CHRISTIAN DEMOCRAT governments.
And within the CHRISTIAN DEMOCRATS is a man
you should know.
His name was GIULIO ANDREOTTI, the man who
became Prime Minister 7 different times, and
the real godfather of Christian Democracy.
For years, no Italian politician could do
anything without being blessed by Mr. Andreotti.
“Power wears out those who don´t have it”
—Giulio Andreotti
And now you might wonder…
What did Christian Democrats stad for?
Well…
Christian Democracy was, basically, what we
call a catch-up-all-party.
Anyone except a communist could find his or
her place inside of this party.
And this included deals with the Napolitan
CAMORRA, the Sicilian COSA NOSTRA and, allegedly,
extreme right wing groups that terrorized
the country during the 80s.
But we will talk about this in another video.
The important thing is, Andreotti and his
Christian Democrats badly needed the popular
support.
You know,
you need to win some elections.
And, in order to do that, what’s better
than employing people with a good salary?
You see…
Italy has over 3.5 million civil servants
and they are among the highest paid in the
entire World.
This means a crazy amount of public spendng
and lots of bureaucracy.
In fact, since Andreotti’s time until now,
Italy is famous for two things: red tape and
ineffective courts.
For a better understanding, let’s imagine
we have a company that produces construction
machines and we have a client who doesn’t
pay.
We take him to the courts, right?
If we are in, say, France, this process will
take us around 2 and half months.
Well, in Italy we could wait more than 3 years
before we get our problem solved.
As you can imagine, this is not the best business
climate.
But nevertheless…
I said Italy became one of the wealthiest
countries in all of Europe, right?
How is that possible?
Well, my dear VisualPolitik viewers… the
answer lies in the ITALIAN LIRA.
Yep, you heard that right… having their
own currency, the Italian Central Bank could
devaluate anytime they needed to put their
economy on steroids.
And now you might wonder…
But…
Simon!
Isn’t this the worst thing you could do?
For instance, in this other video, I told
you that Germany became Rich, partly, because
they had a very stable currency, the DEUSTCHE
MARK.
And now I’m telling you the opposite.
How is it possible that Italy Could grow so
much, having so much corruption, red tape
and devaluations?
Well, let’s take a look!
ROCCO SIFFREDI IS “THE UGLY”
Having acted in more than 1700 movies, Rocco
Siffredi, AKA, the Italian Stallion, dominated
the adult section of rental stores worldwide
during the 80s.
And yet, he is a symbol of Italian economy
during that time.
A growth model that relied, heavily on…
inflation.
You see, during the 80s and the 90s, Italy
flooded the world markets with…
CHEAP PRODUCTS.
They were kind of a 20th century China.
As soon as something worked in some other
country, some Italian company would show up
making the same thing, but… cheaper!
Here is an example: western movies.
In America, John Wayne movies were incredibly
successful.
So Italian movie producers started doing more
of the same, but at an industrial level.
This is how the Spaghetti western was born.
And the same happened with other industries.
While Donna Summer was making the entire world
dance, Italians struck back with SABRINA,
who did the same but…
CHEAPER and more explicitly!
And what about Animated movies?
While Disney was launching Aladdin in movie
theatres, the cheap, Italian version, was
already available in all the video clubs.
But they cheaply reproduced more than culture
here!
In general, Italian companies mastered the
art of making cheap things or, as the economists
would say, “low added value manufacturing”.
Italy produced clothes, furniture and plastic
items.
If you bought an animated action figure in
the 90s, it probably had a “Made in Italy”
label somewhere.
But if you bought a Stereo Sound system, it
would have a Made in Germany or Made in Japan
label.
And now the questions is…
Why was the Italian economy so strongly based
on selling cheap things abroad?
Well… look at this chart.
Here you can see the value of the Italian
LIRA against the GERMAN MARK.
As you can see, during the 80s and the 90s,
Italian currency was losing value all the
time.
In 1980, you would get 450 Liras for 1 German
Mark.
15 years later, you could get 1000 liras for
1 German Mark.
So what does this mean?
It means innovation was way more expensive
for Italian companies than German ones.
For instance, imagine we have an Italian production
company during the 80s, and we want to make
a really innovative movie.
Something like Star Wars, with state of the
art special effects and cutting edge technology.
If we want to do that, we’re going to need
to buy that animation software that’s produced
in Japan, and those special cameras from America
that allow us to make battle scenes.
But, since our Italian currency is losing
value all the time, those things are more
expensive for us.
Add to this the fact that, for anything we
do, any shooting outdoors we want to plan
or any new cameraman we have to hire, we need
to cut through never-ending red tape.
This doesn’t sound good, does it?
Now imagine that, instead of making a Star
Wars-like film, we call our friend Rocco Siffredi
and make a
adult movie with him.
We just need a couple of cameras, a room and
a bed.
And… since we have a weak currency, we can
sell our movies abroad for a lower price than
any other film.
So… with this model, the Italian economy
grew sky high…
During these years, thousands of small companies
were born.
But make no mistake!
Italian SMEs had nothing to do with German
SMEs.
You see, German Mittlestands had between 50
and 200 workers.
And they had enough scale to invest money
on research and innovation.
Italian companies were way smaller, their
methods were more traditional, and their industries
were… well, more illegal…
…when Italy started taking account of its
shadow economy, (…) which makes up about
a fifth of Italian
GDP.
As a result, the economy grew by 18% overnight
So now you might wonder…
Why should Italians innovate so much if they
were doing well by not doing it?
Well… now I will tell you why…
SILVIO BERLUSCONI IS “THE UGLY”
This is, finally, the 21st century.
Christian Democracy is not that important
anymore.
Now, the brand new leader of the center right
wing is this man you see on the screen…
his name is SILVIO BERLUSCONI.
I have little hair because my brain is so
big it pushes everything else out.
—Silvio Berlusconi
2002 was not the best year to be the Italian
Prime Minister.
DO you know why?
Well, because 2002 was the year Italy abandoned
the Italian Lira and started using the EURO.
And what’s the main characteristic of the
EURO?
Here, no government can decide, by itself,
how to devaluate it.
Euros are issued by the European Central Bank,
which includes representatives of all the
member countries.
This was a big problem for a country like
Italy, who had become so addicted to devaluation.
But things don’t stop there!
Do you remember another thing that happened
at the beginning of the 2000s?
Oh really?
You don’t remember?
Well, let me refresh your memory!!
China joins the World Trade Organization - at
last
And now you might wonder…
What does China have to do with the Italian
economy?
Oh man… a lot!
The fact that CHina had joined the World Trade
Organization was a symptom of something bigger.
It meant that all of Asia was flooding the
international markets.
It was not only China.
Other countries like Thailand and Bangladesh
were already becoming big manufacturing powerhouses.
And… surprise!
Surprise!
What did these countries start manufacturing
first?
Exactly!
Cheap things!
The same as the Italians did… but even cheaper!
Back then, Germany was already a behemoth,
technology wise.
So, despite the Asian competition, their products
were still competitive.
Meanwhile, Italy could not go back to good
old devaluation.
First, they were part of the euro now.
Second, devaluating wasn’t a solution against
Asia’s cheap salaries.
Here is an example: one of the most symbolic
Italian companies is FIAT.
In 1990, they sold over 1,300,300 cars in
Europe.
Now, they just sell 700,000 and they can’t
get into new markets.
Other brands like BMW still maintain their
shares on their traditional markets and they
are growing in emerging countries like China.
But wait a minute because things don’t stop
here!
Do you remember how Italy had over 3 million
civil servants?
Well, they are still there!
And they have to be paid!
In other words, while the Italian economy
is falling, their government collects less
and less taxes, but spending remains the same.
SO what does this mean?
It means Italy is now the 4th most indebted
country on the planet.
Their public debt is over 130% of their GDP.
And this, my dear viewers, is just CRAZY!
Italy Is Europe's Next Big Problem
So now the question is…
Should Italy abandon the euro so they can
go back to their devaluation and cheap
manufacturing model?
Or maybe they should follow the German model
and let their companies innovate?
Please, leave your answer in the comment section
below.
And… sorry what did you just say?
You don’t know how the German economic model
works?
Oh come on, just click on this other video
and you’ll learn everything you need to
know about Germany’s economy!
Also don’t forget to visit the RECONSIDER
MEDIA podcast, the podcast that provided the
voices in this video that are not mine.
And, as always, don’t forget we publish
brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday
so hit that subscribe button and you will
not miss a single post.
If you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up, and I’ll see you next time.